they spent about two weeks since I've
talked about Doctor Who I think it's too
long so I can't stop myself I am on a
roll with doing lists related to Doctor
Who and this one was actually suggested
but in some of the comments by a couple
of different people I'm gonna rank the
series of new Doctor Who breaking them
all down breaking them starting with the
worst going up to the best I'll try and
keep the preamble short but honestly
this was really really hard and it was
something I've never really done because
I and I feel I need to be real emphatic
about this at the start I don't believe
there is a bad series of Doctor Who even
the ones that I put at the very bottom I
still liked I am NOT one of those fans
who goes ah that year was crap I've
never had that experience with Doctor
Who I've had specific episodes I didn't
like but I've never had a series as a
whole or I was like oh what a waste of
my time one last thing I do have to
mention even though there's been 10
series I've actually got 11 entries
because I'm counting the specials as
their own separate thing which I'm
effectively counting is the series so
that is enough preamble starting at the
bottom series seven and I was I don't
want to say it was shocked but I was a
little surprised because I mean I see a
lot of forms on a lot of other videos
people love to crap all over series 7
and until I sat down to do this ranking
I had a hard time figuring out why
because I enjoyed it for the most part
until I really had to compare it to the
other ones now series 7 was the one
where they broke up the series halfway
through first of all that structure does
the series no favors it means it feels
like two small series rather than one
big one it doesn't have much structure
in any larger sense and then for me part
of the other problem is the addition of
Clara
now I Clara did grow on me eventually
but she started out in a rough place
because when she first shows up she's
not a character she's a mystery box
she's a plot point she does
doing like I was way more interested in
the future iteration of her we saw an
asylum of the Daleks and the Victoria
narration we saw her in the snowmen then
I was with the version we actually got
but even if I look at the front half
which is the one with Amy and Rory which
I think is better overall than the back
half of this thing there's still some
not great stuff in this I think
ultimately the capital was that I kind
of struggled to figure out the standout
episode of this series I mean I guess it
would either be asylum of the Daleks or
name of the doctor but that's the first
and last episode of series that means
that there's a whole lot of white noise
in the middle of this thing I mean a
couple of high points there's some ones
I still like in there but those are the
only two that I'm like yeah those are
real good episodes and that's not a
great batting average for this thing so
that occupies the bottom spot moving up
to an odd space number 10 that will
bring us to series 2 which also
surprised me a little bit it's funny
I've actually had people comment mainly
on my worst episodes list
that a boy I must hate series 2 and in
my head I don't act honestly some of my
favorite episodes are in series 2 but
it's also got a lot of clunkers I mean
you know for every Satan pit and
impossible planet and doomsday we get
stuff like new earth and love and
monsters and fear her or the idiots
Lantern I mean there's still some saving
graces there's school reunion which is
good there's girl in the fireplace which
is great and there's some of the others
I already mentioned but even though it's
got a better batting average than series
7 does which is wise placed higher when
this seat went seems too missed it
missed hard moving up another spot
series 3 I think there's probably the
first one I'm gonna have on here that
I'm gonna get some serious pushback on
from some fans because well look they
aside from there being some phenomenal
episodes in this series blink and I and
the family blood human nature pool but
then there's Daleks in Manhattan which
is painful
the Shakespeare Code in 42 which are
just kind of bland and then if I'm
looking at the series as a whole there's
two other big things I don't love this
take on the master and I talked about
this before so I won't dwell on it too
much I like John Sims later performances
as the master I liked him better when he
was in the end of time I liked him
better when he showed up at the end of
series 10 his initial intro here in
series 3 I didn't love and then there's
the other thing which is Martha and I
know I'm gonna get pushback on this as
well but I don't love Martha but I also
I really stress I want to clarified that
has much more to do with character use
and the way the show kind of treated her
as a character then it does the
performance of the actual
characterization because I actually
think Martha is a very good character
she's a strong character I think she's a
character who deserved better than the
show treated her I feel like the show
almost intentionally stacked the deck
against Martha it kept over and over and
over comparing her to Rose and like
deliberately trying it trying to make it
an unfavorable comparison and really
emphasizing how hung up the doctor still
was on Rose and it just turned Martha
into a rebound when she's better than
that so I didn't like how she was
handled in this series overall the
master wasn't doing it for me at this
point and so between those two factors
which are major ones where you're
looking at the series as a whole yeah
this is on the lower end moving up to
the eighth spot appropriately enough is
Series eight which was Peter Capaldi's
first series and I did like Peter
Capaldi pretty much out the gate but I
didn't love him yet not in this series
he would take a little while to grow on
me there's that he wasn't quite fully
connecting with me we're still toting
Clara around and while she started her
chemistry's better with Capaldi than it
was when she was with Matt Smith but
she's only just starting to work for me
as a character in this one I think part
of the thing with series 8 is it's a
series that I enjoyed when it first
aired it's one that probably took the
biggest hit
I revisit it what I realized like some
of the episodes that I thought were
great like listen I actually have a fair
number of issues with when I rewatched
it again and really the only episode
that I'm like yes is mummy on the Orient
Express there are still some of the good
ones flatline is good I like robots of
Sherwood I think death in heaven and the
the finisher pretty strong but overall
it was it was not the strongest debut
that they could have given Capaldi not
terrible by any means but but yeah just
kind of middling moving up to the
seventh spot we stick with Peter Capaldi
and we get series 9 now series 9 I like
Capaldi much better now I know some
people found the whole guitar playing
and the sonic sunglasses everything
really cringey Ike I kind of liked it I
kind of loved it
actually it's this aging rock star vibe
and I think he's really good for that
overall I do think this is a pretty
strong series there's only two falldown
episodes and I'm gonna come back to them
because they are the primary reason this
series isn't higher as a whole but by
this point car and the doctor are
actually really working for me they're
gelling very well they've made clara a
proper character and i found it
interesting the whole she was like
trying to be him and the doctor was like
don't try and be me that's a bad idea
and that actually leads to her death and
face the Raven which was good and oh
this this sees this series had
heaven-sent
oh my god that episode and that one is
one I was so happy to revisit and
realize no it's still just as good as I
remember it thank you
but then we've got the fall downs
first there's Sleep No More which just
yeah it may want to make my worst
episodes list and but then there's
hell-bent now my opinion the the exact
nature of my opinion on how bent has
wavered over time it's gone up and down
initially I was just befuddled and
confused by this and I didn't know what
to make of it
then I kind of through the help of
I kind of understood what it was doing
better so I couldn't say it failed at
what it was doing but I still didn't
like it and now as more time has passed
I've actually come to really dislike it
again a lot of it having to do with its
intent as well as its execution and that
that episode alone honestly really drags
this this series down partly because
it's the finale and partly because it
impacts and and what happens in this
impact so many other things that I can't
just deal with it as an isolated oh that
was just one bad episode like I can with
other clunkers in other series there's
too much tied up in that one moving up
to the sixth place spot we have the
David Tennant specials so in case you
don't remember that means the next
doctor the dead planet the waters of
Mars and the end of time parts one and
two now I don't think that there is a
complete junk episode out of this lot I
think probably the weakest one is plant
out of the Dead or dead planet or what I
could on ax Steven I'm having a hard
time remembering what the title was
which I think shows the the falls out of
that one it's fine it's functional
there's nothing really wrong with it but
it's pretty generic it's not
particularly memorable I actually have a
really soft spot for the next Doctor I
really find it sweet and endearing and
I'm there's a lot of aspects I like
about that episode with waters of Mars I
know I have downplayed that episode
before because I a lot of people have a
lot stronger love for that episode than
I do but it is still very good even if
I'm don't put it on the same pedestal
other people do and the end of time
seems to be surprisingly divisive I
think a lot of people are down on how
drawn-out the endings and the goodbyes
are and I get that but kind of like with
the end of Return of the King for me for
the journey we've been through I thought
it felt earned and we get what for me
was an iteration of the master that I
liked a lot better than he was the first
time we get the return of the time
Lloyd's and Timothy Dalton we get we
hear Wilf I love Wilf
and overall I think this is just a
strong set of episodes I'm not sure
anything is quite truly stellar I mean
if I were to pick a favorite of this lot
it would be the end of time but I still
recognize there are some sort of
structural issues with the end of time
and I understand why other people have
problems with it I can still enjoy it
but that gets it you're basically dead
center of this list so we can get into
what I can safely call the upper half
which brings us to number 5 series 1
this one I actually didn't think was
going to make it this high because it's
probably almost a 50/50 split between
episodes I like and episodes I don't but
first off we've got Dalek and we've got
the empty child and the doctor dances
which those two stories those are some
of my favourite Doctor Who ever I adore
those stories and honestly maybe gets
bumped up artificially because of this
but this was Christopher Eccleston the
only series and even in the episodes I
don't love I really liked him as the
doctor I like number 9 I like him a lot
and I wish we could have gotten more
time with him and you know maybe I'm
boosting the series placement overall
because of him more than the strength of
the series as a whole but if that's even
if that's the case so be it in fourth
place we have series 6 which is another
series that I hear a lot of people have
issues with that I I can't say that
they're wrong I just don't share them
first of all I really like Amy and Rory
and I think this stretch of episodes is
where the dynamic of the two of them
with the doctor in that trio was really
firing on all cylinders
I like River saw her like her use in
this I like the reveals we get about her
I like the Impossible Astronaut I like a
good man goes to war I love the doctor's
wife I really like the god complex I
feel like over all this this is the
series where mass meth and these
companions were at their most
comfortable they were their most fun
they were their most energetic plus the
series was the introduction to the
silence and I know this is blasphemy in
some circles but I like the silence
better than the weeping angels I mean
that's just me
personally because you know the idea
that they messed with your head and you
can't remember that just it's my buttons
a little harder than living statues but
they just work better for me we are
getting right up there top three spots
now number three series five Matt
Smith's first series now even though I
said before I think series six the
overall team dynamic between Amy Rory
and the doctor was working best then I
think actual overall writing and the
episodes themselves are stronger in
series five and now I had a hard time
figuring out which with those was gonna
come out on top of the other and if I
did this list again maybe I'd switch
them around but this is where they're
landing for right now and I've said
before the eleventh hour was a
phenomenal opening and intro to not only
Matt Smith's doctor but also Amy and how
their dynamic was gonna work I think the
series has one of the better mystery box
story mysteries over the course of the
series overall it's got the return of
the weeping angels it's got the doctor
and Vincent which is an episode that
I've really come to appreciate as time
has gone on this was just a heck of a
starter for Matt Smith and it's yeah
it's right up there getting up to top
two and if you've been keeping track and
doing your math you realize what the
last two are gonna be and that does mean
that the number two spot surprised me I
was not expecting this one to land this
high I really wasn't but what I looked
at things overall like yeah
number two series 10 the most recent
series that finished airing first of all
this is Capaldi at his best so far as
I'm concerned I think he got better
every single series that he was on and
by the time he finished I absolutely
loved him I love Bill
I was so sure based on some of the
pre-release material that they put out
that I was gonna hate Bill I loved her I
loved nardole I loved Missy so for me
this series has possibly the best sort
of series long elements ever and then it
comes down to having some really good
individual episodes on top of that we've
got oxygen we've got extremists we've
got world enough in time war and to my
way of thinking no real clunker episodes
I think probably the weakest was empress
of Mars but even that was fine this was
just a
really good solid series and it made me
all the more sad that Capaldi was
leaving because this man it just kept
getting better and I wish I could have
seen what we would have gone with one
more series but that does mean we are at
the number one spot in my opinion the
best series of Doctor Who series four
first off let's be upfront Don is my
favorite companion by a pretty decent
margin and I've said that before and
I'll reiterate it now and that goes a
long way towards really lifting the
series up as a whole I think I've
realized as I more to this series that
the overall elements that you've that
stretch across the whole series are more
likely to booyah series over some a
couple of wonky episodes then a few
stellar episodes are to Bowie a series
that otherwise just has a lot of
elements that aren't working for me
I think Don is a good example of that I
think the again this is one of the
better mystery boxes with the
appearances of Rosen not knowing how
that's working as we find out as we go
on but then if we want to get down into
individual episodes on top of that
midnight silence in the library we got
the return of Davros Sontarans the OOD
fires a Pompeii which had to be fair was
lent additional poignancy by Capaldi's
coming back because the doctor but just
this oh man this is a great series you
know I'm not saying it's perfect there
are a couple of ones that I'm not a big
fan of in here I don't really think the
doctor's daughter works it really needed
to be a two-parter I've got issues with
certain elements of unicorn the wasa
they don't quite work for me
partners in crime is good not great but
what I'm looking at series overall the
big picture for me it's series four but
like I said these were all good series
of television as far as I'm concerned
but that's my own personal ranking
assuming you've made it to the end and
didn't switch off because I gave a
little ranking to your favorite series
what are your thoughts on this list how
would you order it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe as I am
contractually obligated to remind you to
do check me out on Twitter at Council of
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher I'm also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast
it's also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]